contrairement à la plupart des longs
qu'ils vont dire donc elle ne dirais pas
que je suis rarement il vous dirait que
je suis est normal que je suis devenu
redondant
il voudrait que j'ai déjà mieux traités
qu'aujourd'hui
bonsoir je m'appelle colline à 19 ans
jean castex par blue hill je suis venu à
l'aller ils blessures physiques comme ça
quelques jours j'ai longtemps de tester
cette blessure je me suis acharné contre
et en fait c'est vers 1h 10 ans qu'elle
a commencé à poser problème c'est comme
je me suis plus lent qu'au coeur des
choses et que les autres nous voyons
deux mois que mon et de travail mâchoire
asymétrique que c'est devenu
insupportable et que j'aime bien ça
c'est du fait d'une claque mais monnet à
ce bon voila j'ai décidé de commencer
par fonctionnel d'ailleurs à cet appel à
la chirurgie reconstructrices à la
chirurgie esthétique
j'avance je suis assez d'accord avec ce
terme parce que en un sens on peut dire
que j'étais détruite puis reconstruite
un peu comme mon propos les moeurs et
tarascon va connaître une toile c'est
l'idée que j'allais quand j'étais du sud
évoquée pas seulement dans ma formation
j'arrive en fait si ce n'est la chaleur
montrer votre réponse et eric parce que
je me sentais obligé de le faire
comme pour justifier mon apparence quand
on discutait pas être comme ça comme
pour dire
je suis comme ça nuise pas au vote vous
n'avez jamais accuser les parents tdk la
fusée de génétique ils arrêtent activité
poney l'accusé du corps n'accusez pas
jamais longtemps fait et ce sentiment de
monde ce sentiment domine cette aventure
là dessus et j'étais frustré aussi de
pas avoir les bons mots pour dire qu'il
est et ce que je ressentais d'où j'ai
essayé d'exister autrement qu'à travers
cette malformation
je suis devenu combien de ma classe en
primaire au collège au lycée invention
très bien finalement ça ne rentrait pas
donc je pense que je ne suis pas trop
mal débrouillé il a trépassé vraiment
quelque chose d'extraordinaire des gens
préparent les confronter à ces vitaux
connex examen robot surtout vous
entretiens de personnalités qui sont
assez fréquentes une guerre commerciale
il a fallu assez vite que j'appelais
papa de formation et c'est pour ça que
mon entourage été surpris comme moi la
cabine m'a fourni jeudi cette voie on
est 100 a explosé physiquement je
transcris notre personnalité notre
histoire
moi c'est évident c'était la seule voir
qu'elle est à même d'exploiter ma
blessure au traitement des prestations
fictives
il sait exactement ce qui est en train
de faire cette année j'ai fait une belle
rencontre
au bout d'un an je pense j'ai rencontré
la coupe de france est pas qui est un
vendredi matin
nous allumer la lumière de votre part ou
si tu cherches à exploiter la matière
grise notre classe au sujet du thabor
dans notre profession va proposer des
lectures de textes sur ce thème qui va
vous m'inspirez que j'ai écrit en tête
je me suis dit que c'était peut-être le
moment pour qu'il y ait beaucoup et que
peut-être fatigué car les montants
touchés brio ce texte parce qu'il manie
si je l'avais dit ouah la normalité
n'existe pas senna gagne +4 concertation
ça nous a tous dans la laure vision a
voulu assez extravagante green ou pas
toutefois ne faisons pas trop de bruit
on essaie de bien des vies darabont le
feu c'est quelque chose qui nous
montrait vivent ou ont vécu en danger et
ont tous ensemble et on va appliquer de
ce qui ne me ressemble pas je ne suis
pas normal parce que titanic il ne me
fais pas ma belle tu t'amuses de figure
je les pages du récit des manques elle
flottait entre sérieux il a déjà la
pression des sauveteurs
je me suis fait normal parce que les
débats ne goûte que les faits d'une
violence l'airé du devoir de maths
depuis la 5e par c'est la science
fiction mali seulement voilà avec magic
c'est une prophétie génial que je
néglige aucun cas des personnes dans la
toute petite vie alors oui je t'aime
distribuer comme des préservatifs à
ce que titre mously lô passé et que les
chiffons polisario gars m'ont connu la
poterie est pas une excuse à sion parce
que je vais pas quand il faut que
j'observais le faut parce que je suis
bien en vo transit parce que je ne suis
pas comme nous tous comme vous parce que
la poésie n'a sauvé dans quel monde je
ne suis pas normal parce que je suis
tatouée depuis que j'ai 14 ans voilà
maintenant c'est peut-être eu pour y
voler je mets la main un petit nuage en
raison de la rivalité votre boss muller
qui ne veut créer que des chiffres
difficiles qui ont manqué d'attention
qui aime le rose le salon toutes sortes
elle pense que ça chatouille le
plastique les musiques eau chaude qui
pensent que chaque pays a sa propre rôle
et évidemment qui ont construit leur
religion dessus de la fosse à gauche
mais en confirmant leur ami tort pour
évoquer cette terminale albiol vous
l'avez deviné pas c'était pour la vie
mais ça l'est resté à la douche est le
cède à peine formé des chatrooms ya 18
ans on en sera ouverte c'est sûr qu'elle
n'a pas caché son corps de cette façon
quelle tristesse cette société de la
tente du faux du mensonge
j'ai regardé mon âge j'ai mis des
pressions sur le champ et je veux des
communes et des skins qui dépasse de
même temps celle des prisonniers et à
toutes les aubaines et méchant garçon
ait pas de 24 cents mais vous savez
madame cette année je n'ai jamais pu
appuyer ces machines pourtant mais non
est la vision de certains jeux médical
il est le papa elle m'est cher il décide
de tout est fait cas des très jeunes gt
rien
elle veut tout faire et c'est un corps
et âme à chaque fois la gym le karaté
théâtre et de la danse
elle a besoin de couvrir l'événement
elle est en colère aussi tellement en
colère mais elle est aussi passionnée
elle est anti l'asse salle où elle adore
son père parce qu'ils ne ressemblaient
pas du tout parce qu'il est mesuré
patients et l'inclusion lequel et vous
savez avec les ventes avant pharmacien
est un visionnaire et un sens très bien
ce n'est pas normal j'ai choisi cette
voie commerciale
je ne suis pas normal parce que je la
vois pas là parce que je n'aime pas les
gens mangent que les choque pas trop
importante dans ma vie que j'ai l'appui
il est sain minuit le chocolat noir que
les silences que j'ai du talent au bon
moment écoutez et que j'écoute tout ce
que je peux dire c'est qu'il ya de mieux
chez bien ce qui le rend en blanc c'est
que de subir de 15 ans qui concerne 16
naissances chaque année en france c'est
sûr des sens et demi j'en ai la chance
j'ai vu l'appel comme harry potter c'est
un comportement étrange qui vous
semblent d'invités de pâtes italiennes
impossible d'orthographier ce qui vient
c'est à cause de lui l'enfant de 80
n'était pas une aile quant à lui le
corps d'une attitude plus aucune
planteurs plus aucune illusion elles
pouvaient déjà repêché vers d'autres
cultures c'est mon bébé
il n'est pas normal 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5
qu'est ce que vous faites je compte six
grands madame lise répondent qu'ils
montrent du doigt ce bébé là mais elle
est lassée du toit elle est juste un peu
décalé déplacer made for me for you know
chez radoux votre bébé terme
enfin bras je vois pas souvent dit comme
ça c'est grâce à ça que j'ai remonté le
docteur cactus 32 51 me choque les
enfers dont j'ai besoin
si tu es dunes militaire valable à 9 ans
je lui ai dit c'est quelque chose avant
que leur coeur bat démolissent il a
compris il a trouvé ça normal
j'étais jeune on a les yeux les autres
je termine dans mon miroir le suis
devenu j'ai essayé de tout les sens de
me noyer dans la masse d'être comme tout
le monde quelle belle il faut rester à
la surface
on sort mi temps les avis
j'ai voulu être cemetery comment bien
vos pensionnaires d'un tableau de degas
aussi mais a pris 3,16 gros bloc je
reste un picasso